BARTON ZWIEBACH: We want to
understand now our observables.
So we said these
are observables,
so can we observe them?
Can we have a state in which we
say, what is the value of Lx,
the value of Ly,
and the value of Lz.
Well, a little
caution is necessary
because we have states and
we have position and momentum
operator and they didn't
commute and we ended up
that we could not
tell simultaneously
the position and the
momentum of a state.
So for this angular momentum
operators, they don't commute,
so a similar situation
may be happening.
So I want to explain,
for example, or ask,
can we have simultaneous
eigenstates of Lx, Ly, and Lz?
And the answer is no.
And let's see why that happens.
So let's assume we can have
simultaneous eigenstates
and let's assume, for example,
that Lx on that eigenstate phi
nought is some number
lambda x phi nought,
and Ly and phi nought is
equal to lambda y phi nought.
Well, the difficulty with
this is essentially--
well, we could even say
that Lz on phi nought
is equal to lambda z phi nought.
So what is the complication?
The complication are
those commutators.
If you do Lx, Ly and
phi nought, you're
supposed to get i h-bar
Lz and phi nought.
And therefore, you're
supposed to get i h-bar lambda
z times phi nought, because it's
supposed to be an eigenstate.
But how about the
left hand side?
The left hand side is LxLy
and phi nought minus LyLx
and phi nought.
When Ly acts, it produces a
lambda y, but then phi nought,
and then when Lx acts,
it produces a lambda x,
so this produces lambda x lambda
y phi nought minus lambda y
lambda x phi nought,
which is the same thing,
so the left hand side is 0.
0 is equal to lambda z
phi nought, so you get a--
lambda z must be 0.
If you have a non-trivial
state, lambda z should be 0.
By the other commutators--
this can be attained or
applied to phi nought--
would be 0 again, because
each term produces a number
and the order doesn't matter.
But then it would show
that lambda x is 0,
and this will show
that lambda y is 0.
So at the end of the day,
if these three things hold,
then all of them are 0.
Lambda x equals lambda y
equals lambda z equals 0.
So you can have something
that is killed by all
of the operators, but you cannot
have a non-trivial state with
non-trivial eigenvalues
of these things.
So we cannot have--
we cannot tell what is Lx on
this state and Ly on this state
simultaneously.
Any of those two is too much.
So if we can't tell
that, what can we tell?
So what is the most we
can tell about this state
Is our question now.
We can tell maybe what
is its value of Lx,
but then Ly and Lz
are undetermined.
Or we can tell
what is Lz and then
Lx and Ly are undetermined,
incalculable, impossible
in principle to calculate them.
So let's see what we
can do, and the answer
comes from a rather
surprising thing, the fact
that if you think about what
could commute with Lx, Ly, Lz,
it should be a rotationally
invariant thing, because Lx,
Ly, and Lz do rotations.
So the only thing
that could possibly
commute with this
thing is something
that is rotationally invariant.
The thing that could work out
is some thing that is invariant
and there are rotations.
Now we said, for example,
the magnitude of the vector R
is invariant under rotation.
You rotate the vector,
the demanded is invariant.
So we can try the
operator L squared,
which is proportionate
to the magnitude squared,
so we define it to be
LxLx plus LyLy plus LzLz.
And we tried, we tried to see
if maybe Lx commutes with L
squared.
Remember, we had a role for L
squared in this differential
operator that had the
Laplacian, the angular part
of the Laplacian was
our role for L squared,
so L squared is
starting to come back.
So let's see here--
this is Lx-- now, I'll
write the whole thing--
LxLx plus LyLy plus LzLz.
Now, Lx and Lx
commute, so I don't
have to bother with
this thing, that's 0.
But the other ones
don't commute.
So let's do the
distributive law.
So this would be an Lx,
Ly Ly plus Ly Lx, Ly--
this is from the first--
plus Lx, Lz Lz plus Lz Lx, Lz.
You know, if you don't put these
operators in the right order,
you don't get the right answer.
So I think I did.
Yes.
It's correct.
Now you use the commutators
and hope for the best.
So Lx, Ly is i h-bar LzLy.
Lx, Ly is plus i h-bar LyLz.
So far, no signs of
canceling, these two things
are very different
from each other.
They don't even appear
with a minus sign,
so this is not a commutator,
but anyway, what is this?
Lx with Lz.
Well, you should always
think cyclically.
Lz with Lx is i h-bar, so this
would be minus i h-bar LyLz,
and this is again Lz with Lx
would have been i h-bar Ly,
so this is minus i h-bar
LzLy, and it better cancel--
yes.
This term cancels with the first
and this term cancels with this
and you get 0.
That's an incredible
relief, because now you
have a second operator that
is measurable simultaneously.
You can get eigenstates that are
eigenstates of one of the L's--
for example, Lx and L
squared, because they commute,
and you won't have the
problems you have there.
In fact, it's a general theorem
of linear algebra that--
we'll see a little bit of
that in this course and you'll
see it more completely in 805--
that if you have two Hermitian
operators that commute,
you can find a simultaneous
eigenstates of both operators.
I mean, eigenstates that
are eigenstates of 1,
and eigenstates of the second.
Simultaneous eigenstates
are possible.
So we can find simultaneous
eigenstates of these operators,
and in fact, you could find
simultaneous eigenstates of Lx
and L squared, but given
the simplicity of all this,
it also means that Ly
commutes with L squared,
and that Lz also
commutes with L squared.
So you have a choice--
you can choose Lx,
Ly, or Lz and L
squared and try to form
simultaneous eigenstates
from all these operators.
Two of them.
Let's study those operators
as differential operators
a little bit.
So x, y, and z are your
spherical coordinates
and they are r sin theta
cos phi, r sin theta sin
phi, and r cos theta.
We're trying to calculate
the differential
operators associated
with angular momentum
using spherical coordinates.
So r is x squared plus y
squared plus z squared.
Theta is cosine minus 1 of z
over r and 5 is tan minus 1 y
over z.
And there's something very
nice about one angular momentum
operator in spherical
coordinates,
there is only one angular
momentum that is very simple--
its rotations about z.
Rotations about z
don't change the angle
theta of spherical coordinates,
just change the angle phi.
r doesn't change.
The other rotation, the rotation
about x messes up phi and theta
and all the others
are complicated,
so maybe we can have some luck
and understand what is d/d-phi,
the d/d-phi operator.
Well, the d/d-phi operator
is d/dy dy/d-phi plus d/dx
dx/d-phi--
the rules of chain rule
for partial derivatives--
plus d/dz dz/d-phi.
But z doesn't depend on phi.
On the other hand,
dy/d-phi is what?
dy/d-phi, this becomes
a cos phi-- it's x.
X d/dy.
And dx/d-phi is minus y.
And you say, wow,
x d/dy is like x
py minus y px, that's a z
component of angular momentum!
So indeed, Lz, which is h-bar
over i x d/dy minus y d/dx,
h-bar over i is
because of the p's--
x py minus y px.
And this thing is d/d-phi,
so Lz, we discover,
is just h-bar over i d/d-phi.
A very nice equation
that tells you
that the angular momentum
in the z direction
is associated with its operator.
So I have left us exercises to
calculate the other operators
that are more messy, and
to calculate Lx Ly as well
in terms of d/d-theta's
and d/d-phi's.
And as you remember, angular
momentum has units of h-bar
and angles have no units,
so the units are good
and we should find that.
So that calculation is
left as an exercise,
but now you probably could
believe that L squared,
which is LxLx plus LyLy plus
LzLz is really minus h squared
1 over sin theta d/d-theta.
No, it's-- not 1
over sin theta--
uh, yep.
1 sin theta d/d-theta--
sin theta d/d-theta plus 1 over
sin squared theta d second d
phi squared.
So the claim that they had
relating the angular momentum
operator to the
Laplacian is true.
But, you know, you
now see the beginning
of how you calculate
these things,
but it will be a simple and
nice exercise for you to do it.